l'année 1929 venait tout juste de
commencer
il ne nous restait plus qu'à choisir
comment nous allions débuter cette
nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvions remettre notre destin
entre les mains de la justice veut bien
nous débarrasser d'un cadavre il
continuait à profiter de notre liberté
qu'est ce que c'était ça me sera égale
que tu sors envoyée mais je suis revenu
récupérer ce qui appartient à ma famille
j'étais déjà dit que je te soutiendrai
autant que je peux carlotta je veux je
veux comprendre ce qui m'arrive écoute
moi bien
pablo est qu'à moi je suis une voleuse
de fiancés les ja maintenant je suis
libre
en relais final je voudrais vous poser
quelques questions
j'ai par marca tué bien plus forte que
tu ne le croit souvent que toutes mes
quatre tout se passera bien
je vous en prie ne me laissez passer
toujours carlos je veux être avec toi
francisco j'ai
commences tu encore venir ici après tout
ce qui s'est passé je suis venu aider à
détruire les cas
[Musique]
la seule chose à faire pour l'instant
c'est se taire
[Musique]
il vaut mieux que certains secrets soit
enfouie à tout jamais
[Musique]
elle